>>> TONIGHT GEORA'S FACT
ELECTORS WHO TRIED TO OVERTURN
THE STATE'S 2020 ELECTION
RESULTS IN FAVOR OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP ARE SET TO TESTIFY IN THE
COMING DAYS.
11 OF THE 16 REPUBLICANS ARE
EXPECTED TO APPEAR.
THEIR SCHEME IS LAID OUT IN
EMAILS OBTAINED BY "THE NEW YORK
TIMES."
ONE OF THEM SENT BY BORIS
EPSTEIN TALKS ABOUT AN IDEA
PROPOSED BY A LAWYER WORKING
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THIS EMAIL READS IN PART, HIS
IDEA IS BASICALLY THAT ALL OF
US, GEORGIA, WISCONSIN, ARIZONA,
PENNSYLVANIA HAVE OUR ELECTORS
TURN IN OUR VOTES.
NICK VALENCIA IS "OUTFRONT."
>> Reporter: A SIGNIFICANT LEAK
FOR GEORGIA PROSECUTORS
INVESTIGATION THE ALLEGED
INTERFERENCE BY DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS ADVISERS.
THERE'S 11 REPUBLICANS ARE
EXPECTED TO APPEAR IN THE
SPECIAL GRAND JURY.
AMONG THEM IS THE STATE'S GOP
PARTY CHAIR DAVID SHAFFER.
>> MOST OF THESE FOLKS COULD
WALK RIGHT INTO THE COURTHOUSE
AND THOSE CAMERAS WOULDN'T EVEN
PIVOT ON THEM.
>> Reporter: THE SO-CALLED FAKE
ELECTORS ARE TARGETS OF AN
INVESTIGATION FOR PARTICIPATING
IN A PLAN TO SUBVERT THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE AND ASSERT
TRUMP WAS THE WINNER IN GEORGIA
IN THE 2020 ELECTION.
EVEN AS THE FULTON COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY APPEARS POISED
TO CHARGE CRIMINALLY, THIS WEEK
A MAJOR MISSTEP.
>> THE OPTICS ARE HORRIFIC.
>> Reporter: A JUDGE ON MONDAY
BLOCKING WILLIS FROM PURSUING A
CASE AGAINST BURT JONES, A
REPUBLICAN STATE SENATOR WHO IS
RUNNING TO BE GEORGIA'S LT.
GOVERNOR.
>> IT'S NOT A LOWER CASE "A"
APPEARANCE.
IT'S LIKE A CAPITAL "A" WITH
FLASHING LIGHTS.
FUNDRAISER FOR AN OPPONENT OF
SOMEONE I'VE TARGETED IN MY
INVESTIGATION.
>> Reporter: IT COULD NOW IMPACT
THE OVERALL CASE.
A NEW DISTRICT ATTORNEY COULD BE
ASSIGNED TO QUESTION JONES, IF
NEEDED, WHICH COULD CREATE
PROBLEMS.
THE PROSECUTING ATTORNEY'S
COUNSEL OF GEORGIA WHO COULD
APPOINT THE SPECIAL D.A. SAYS NO
DECISION HAS BEEN MADE.
>> WHILE IT MATTERS WHENEVER
THERE'S A DISQUALIFICATION, IN
THIS CASE THE GRAND JURY REVIEW
MOVES FORWARD AND IT DOES NOT
AFFECT THE MOST IMPORTANT TARGET
OF ALL, POTENTIALLY, DONALD
TRUMP.
>> THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA ARE
ANGRY.
THE PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY ARE
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
SAYING THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU
RECALCULATED.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, THE CHALLENGE
YOU HAVE IS THE DATA YOU HAVE IS
WRONG.
>> Reporter: A CASE SPARKED BY
AN INFAMOUS PHONE CALL BY TRUMP
AND GEORGIA'S SECRETARY OF STATE
BRAD RAFFENSPERGER.
NOW AT LEAST SEVEN KEY TRUMP
ALLIES HAVE BEEN SUBPOENAED TO
TESTIFY BEFORE THE GRAND JURY,
INCLUDING FIVE OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN'S LEGAL COUNSELORS, AS
WELL AS THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY
RUDY GIULIANI AND SOUTH CAROLINA
REPUBLICAN SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
ERIN, WE LEARNED ACCORDING TO A
SPOKESPERSON WITH THE GEORGIA
STATE BAR THAT TWO REPUBLICAN
ATTORNEYS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME ARE
HAVING THEIR LAW LICENSES
INVESTIGATED.
A COMPLAINT WAS FILED BY A GROUP
OF LAWYERS EARLIER THIS YEAR.
NOW NOT ONLY ARE T